danielle darrieux je vois vous avez
d'excellentes critiques en particulier
dans le new york times seconde il que
l'actrice française a ajouté de
l'authenticité au rôle et on loue votre
remarquable féminité succéder à
katherine hepburn monstres sacrés
s'attaquer aux états unis à broadway ça
devait être pour vous une entreprise
extrêmement dangereuse qu'est ce que
donnait le courage de le faire
elle veut disons que c'est le courage et
puis là j'ai trouvé que c'était très
très excitant être passionnant d'être de
jouer à broadway
j'ai été très impressionné par katherine
hepburn car j'avais vu je l'avais vu
dans la pièce je me suis dit bon bah
évidemment je ne suis pas katherine
hepburn m'ont fait je veux faire autre
chose j'ai l'accent français c'est une
française coco chanel et puis enfin
c'est une comédie musicale j'avais très
envie de jouer une comédie musicale
oui c'est ce qui a frappé les critiques
en particulier c'est que vous chantiez
katherine hepburn redonnet murray ne
chantait pas mais voilà il ya déjà là
une différence entre nous
en fait les critiques auraient été
formidable pour moi vont vers eux et le
public drôle comment réagit le public
public est très chaleureux et le public
est extraordinaire et si la broadway
mais même en général j allais dans
plusieurs spectacles et je veux dire que
c'est un public extraordinaire mais ça
vous a forcé à à posséder le texte en
anglais et tout le monde admire et votre
anglais est ce que c'est si beau coup
pareil moi j'ai travaillé tout à moi
pour surtout surtout surtout le texte et
là vous allez rester en somme assez
longtemps si tout marche bien que là je
marche bien je rajouterais répéter
jusqu'à l'été prochain et vous aurez
d'autres projets aux états unis en suis
à je ne sais pas vous savez je suis là
aujourd'hui à moi et je suis voir
comment les choses s'organisent et se
font maintenant pour l'instant je suis à
broadway je suis je joue coco et voilà
et vous êtes devenus immédiatement une
grande vedette de broadway et j'en suis
ravi c'est très flatté princesse